good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast quarantine day to help
everyone's enjoying working from home
nobody's killed their husbands
boyfriends significant others
girlfriends yet the morning toast
quarantine Edition y'all it's the best
kind of toasts areas I think how was
your first day
official quarantine working from home UN
Zak oh I mean yesterday was so much
easier than this weekend yesterday for
me was actually day four of the
quarantine no but work from home oh I'm
using because I got to work half the day
I got to be out of the apartment half
the day Zak and I we even do this when
we're not quarantined like I take the
bedroom he takes a living same will sync
up for meals maybe do like an hourly
check-in um so yesterday was actually
quite fabulous I feel like I'm working
hard to keep like my mental health and
my kids of actually my mental health
strong my physical health is out the
door you guys matter I'm eating like a
garbage hey Rock
my work from home Jay one was good I
mean I was a little nervous because Ben
is just like loved him dearly but you
know he's a lot we two separated the
apartment he took the living room I took
the bedroom and the only issue I had is
that maybe I never realized how loud
Ben's voices like he was his whole day
was conference calls first of all he
puts the conference hall on speaker like
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm in the
other room working and then his voice is
so [ __ ] loud my door is closed I'm
like then I could still hear you we have
a scuse me I might come back to throw up
he literally doesn't own a pair of
headphones I'm like can you just lower
your voice you're talking to someone on
the phone you're not screaming at
someone across the street relax I donate
like a little bit of a fight but it was
fine and I think day one went went as
good as it could go a little bit of a
fight is a great start for a quarantine
Zach was on a conference call yesterday
and I was in the kitchen doing the
dishes like you're welcome and I sneezed
and he gave me a look I was ugly I was
like excuse me he's like take him here I
was like everyone in America is dealing
with his people have kids your wife
can't sneeze oh wait also what kind of
special phone are you using that people
on the other side can hear someone in
another room sneezing across the living
room with his ear pads on and he said
that they could hear me sneeze oh my god
the jarama
said shaman yes I have to admit I did
sneeze you guys I'm feeling yeah I was
gonna be like no lecture I don't think
really sneezing no at home
part of the current virus symptoms but I
have been sneezing I'm not gonna lie I'm
sneezing and I'm proud okay it's the
changing of the seasons like soon it's
gonna be allergy season right so a lot
of people are now I was talking Olivia
Zack Shapiro it has really bad allergies
and people are like now confused I think
with symptoms of like seasonal allergies
versus coronavirus me yeah I'm just so
upset that you're coughing and sneezing
but so be Claudia that's beautiful
everyone will understand that what my
comedy special comes out like if it ever
does it's just taking forever
but today you guys we brought you a
special treat because I think what the
world needs right now is dr. Theodore
for Chapman not only for his emotional
support but obviously his medical
expertise so we've brought on a lot of
shows are actually bringing on medical
experts to talk about coronavirus answer
some of your questions and we have the
best in the biz dr. Theodore for
chairman so I mean his Instagram you've
literally no idea has been blowing up
with jams like people just asking like
like I have these same times do you
think I'm okay can my dog carry Colonel
Burton I take Advil a man licked me on
the subway like to think I'm okay things
like that yeah things like that and
that's why we have doctors Theodore fat
Chapman here to answer all of your
burning questions yeah and they're
burning and dr. Theodore for Chapman was
a bad [ __ ] boy this morning no yes I
walked here I mean a nice Duty we're on
our way you know he likes to sniff
around I'll just give him the freedom to
sniff he's a dog and then all of a
sudden each time no all of a sudden he
had a full-blown Cadbury egg in his
mouth and if you know anything about
dogs chocolate is toxic for them so I
was freaking out like literally I had
like it looks like guy Doody on my hand
so michael literally grabbing all the
chocolate out of his mouth and I called
dr. Lisa his veterinarian and she said
she did some calculations Cadbury eggs
people think chocolate is toxic for dogs
and it is but we're talking about like
cacao Cadbury eggs are made of like of
sugar and like 1% and like milk yes so
he's fine he should be fine but I was
freaking out and I'm like where the [ __ ]
did you find a Cadbury egg I didn't know
he had a Cadbury Queen on our hands he's
very British
he's so British it's so cute I know it
was very it was really one of them I've
never been like sweating and it was
raining so I'd like my computer I had
Theo I had my umbrella and like I was
trying not to like touch the ground oh
my god it was so dramatic like I
actually forgot about that part of the
morning
because then you came to the office with
some terrible news and I just I forgot
all about the terribleness that happened
to me this morning but it was very
dramatic yes we not forget you know lest
we need Cadbury egg of it all well at
least he's a man of taste
he is so at least he has that going for
him okay we have a great show for you
today we actually have some stories that
aren't all I mean I would say 70% of the
show will be current on virus related
but that makes sense because 100 percent
of your lives are coronavirus related
we're also gonna be recapping and giving
a new assignment for toast movie of the
day um we'll get to it at the end but I
would just like just be generally if I
may um and just apologize to the
toasters for making them watch a movie
that you know I hadn't seen in a while
and I guess you know people change and
you evolve and you grow and I just
didn't realize that I was making
everyone watch like an absolute piece of
[ __ ] so on behalf of Jackie and I like
we both we deeply apologize we do deeply
apologize um but I'm just gonna play
devil's advocate and say there's a lot
to unpack in the movie agreed and I'm
gonna learn though like it sort of fell
flat after we had just hyped it up so
much um so many great cameos by so many
different actors and actresses are
studded affair
it was so star-studded and I think
there's gonna be like to talk about
which is really all we wanted something
for some discourse on this bleak Tuesday
current morning also in keeping with our
regular programming we are going to do
to your toasters tomorrow so email us
dear toasters at gmail.com if you want
your advice read on air we always keep
it anonymous and I'm thinking if we get
enough submissions maybe doing a
quarantine edition so I could what I was
just thinking that like you're having
some quarantine problems like your
roommates bothering you I don't know you
don't know how to carve out space for
yourself I think that would be like a
good theme you know email us to your
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous but if we don't get any good
ones about quarantine we'll just your
regular ones yeah we'll do whatever even
though like whatever your problem was
before I'm sure hardly exists now it's
like we're going to visit my
mother-in-law too much I'm like I'm sure
you're not seeing her anymore now yeah
right so just relax
um also I just want people to be
discouraged by the chest movie of the
day like I'm reading some of the
comments in the live chat people are
like I'm so glad you agree the movie was
terrible and I just want you to lose
faith in us like we made a mistake and
we have such a good assignment for today
like I think everyone loved it so just
you don't don't lose hope you know I did
see some comments in the groups of
people who really enjoyed the movie I
read a comment of someone who said oh my
god I'm watching the event of lying why
am i crying right now and I think I know
at what scene shoot I don't know why
she's crying but we'll discuss Oh
actually yeah
of course yeah of course okay well
should we just get right into it there's
like literally no sense of time yeah in
these quarren times I also touched
hunters which I would really like to
talk about and I started the bull type
which I really like to talk about okay
are you ever gonna watch the hunt okay
and then I have to tell you how much I
can't stand I stand without wits okay
but then I have to tell you wait can we
save that for your section yeah because
even though there's like no rhyme or
reason as to why it might be time right
now no there's time it's just a social
contract that no longer exists because
society is on pause yeah but I will
venture out there and just like feel my
body class mm-hm and say that is do you
heard something oh it's um it's your
biological clock it's nighttime it's
[ __ ] ticking yeah easy it's time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie but you know what
I think today's sponsor is so pertinent
to the times that we're all living in
because cooking from home has never been
more important or more pertinent and you
can get mouth-watering seasonal recipes
and pre measured ingredients delivered
right to your door with hellofresh
America's number one meal kit hellofresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable I was looking at marker wash
for a story and she said that her
hellofresh like truly saved her life
which is I don't even think about it
like so pertinent I actually just got a
delivery and it's the it's the best most
perfect thing because I actually think
like this quarantine is gonna help teach
a lot of people how to cook like
inadvertently and when hellofresh tells
you sends you all of the supplies that
you need like it couldn't be easier and
all you have is time alright
hello freshest recipes are so delicious
you can break out of your dinner rut
with hello freshers 22 plus seasonal
chef curated recipes each week there's
something for everyone including
low-calorie recipes vegetarian recipes
and family friendly recipes every week
they have more than more five-star
recipes than any other meal kit so you
know you'll get something delicious they
cut out the stressful meal planning and
prepping so you can enjoy cooking and
getting dinner on the table in just 30
minutes or even 20 minutes with some of
their quick recipe options the average
trip to the grocery store takes 41
minutes and that's over 35 hours a year
if you go once a week there
pre-portioned ingredients mean less prep
and more and less food waste the
packaging they used to ship their food
is almost entirely made from recyclable
and or recycled content their carbon
footprint is 25 percent lower than
store-bought grocery meals you can add
extra meals or lunches to your weekly
order throw in some yummy desserts like
garlic bread
cookie dough you can change your
delivery days your food preferences and
skip a week whenever you need so it's
super flexible fit your lifestyle if you
want to you know get our special code
head over to hellofresh comm slash toast
10 and use the code toast 10 for 10 free
meals including free shipping that's
hello fresh comm slash toast 1 0 and the
code is toast 1 0 for 10 free meals
including free shipping head over check
it out thanks hello fresh sign on eat
well
ok first story I think it's the big
story of the day Ursula has tested
positive for coronavirus and so has
torment John Thurmond Giantsbane as as
so have a few other celebrities but
these are the two big clothes an actress
from what the bond series unclear
yesterday with her work easier Salva and
tormund yeah you just Alba put up a
video and I love I love that the
celebrities are being so open and direct
with their bad direct-to-consumer et Cie
but I did think it was weird that he was
like sitting next to his girlfriend or
wife or I don't know and literally being
like you know she hasn't been tested and
she's like literally sitting right there
next it's like girl oh I thought that
was his daughter
oh maybe oh ok but he'll it's a
beautiful young woman who was
susceptible to the virus oh yeah and
he's like yeah she hasn't tested I'm
like oh ok girlfriend run what are you
doing well maybe she's young enough that
it's not a real threat can we talk about
the conspiracy theory that we both read
yes um because I don't think that it's
true I started going around on Twitter
KFC for a bar stool posted it and then
you sent it to me too but I'd seen it in
the toasters and in a fully rated until
yesterday and basically it's this like
really elaborate conspiracy theory that
coronavirus was released on purpose to
cover up like all these major CEO
celebrities like they're gonna get
coronavirus and like step down and die
because it's all a part of this huge
like criminal pedophilia ring yeah
because of the testimony that Jeffrey
Epstein and Harvey Weinstein both
provided the court a good 25 years
instead of 50 he gave the names of many
people involved yes and in order for
Jeffrey Epstein to be able to fake his
own suicide
he gave the names of a lot of people
involved it's a really elaborate
conspiracy theory one that I'm not gonna
buy into but you know I'm always keeping
it in the back of my mind yeah I'll just
keep it in the back nine
as like things happen just keep
cross-referencing but overall I don't
believe it but I think that's what makes
a great conspiracy theory is something
that's unbelievable but like a part of
you just like wants to believe it
well that's that's what's going on in
hunters I'll tell you all about it later
but if that is the case and all these
celebrities and like CEOs who are
getting it means they're involved in
this ring I just don't see that for each
Rossella bub like I I just don't get
crazy I don't see that for tormund I
don't see that for tormund um I don't
really see it for Tom Hanks but then
there's like the chant of it also like
maybe he's involved in some way you know
like I just think this is a really
elaborate conspiracy theory that I'm not
gonna buy into yet but I think it's
always important with conspiracy
theories keep him on the back burner
keep a file you know a little asterisk
never forget yeah but don't like lose
your life with the conspiracy theories
no no that'll just that'll get you into
trouble trouble I also need to talk
about the fact that Chet hangs who has
become somewhat of an icon on the show
he's also become somewhat of a
polarizing figure in society well of
course and we have no choice to stand no
choice um but he was in the critically
acclaimed film I didn't realize was
fathering following in his father's
footsteps he was in the movie brass yeah
and that was just something that had
been lost on me until this weekend same
says I had no idea and it's one of my
favorite fun facts and I feel like
devastated I feel remiss and I feel
really heartbroken about all the times
we've spoken about Chet Hanks and not
attributed that like glorifying accolade
of his you know right we've never even
mentioned it Chet Hanks star of Bratz
okay I wouldn't say star I would say
like minor supporting role but a
breakout star of Bratz should that be a
movie of the day it's so do I know but I
don't think anyone could find a way to
watch it do you um that would be so
important to us it's so important you
know why of course okay yeah we talked
about it on the show go that way cuz of
attitude we've got that chata too you
know oh my god do you know when what we
were yes when we found out our dad died
okay every time we this is what happens
I'm gonna let you know when we have an
ad for attitude we sing we've got that
attitude I know that and then we've got
that attitude and then we say brats what
an amazing movie you can even find out
in the middle that your dad died and
it's still a great film oh you know my
amigas getting so bad oh yeah no we've
shared that with the class everyone's in
on it such a phenomenal movie and
honestly maybe too painful for a toast
movie of the day just it's so uplifting
by the way it's such a good movie that
like I could still watch it or not be
scarred by not be Jerry
like a child like you your favorite
movies and then and then you find out
your dad tied you like blame the movie
but no it's so good I can get past it
the movies what got us through so trio
Jackie's story of four girls coming
together four different girls is um
Janelle
yeah yes she is she's in everything
she'd plays Chet's girlfriend eventually
it's Chet the good or the bad guy he's a
good guy that's a good guy but he was
definitely a lot smaller yes and it and
now he's a lot smaller
he's swole as hell you went from small
to swole we love to see it yeah I feel
like he's like livin not that living for
the fact that his parents have
coronavirus but like living for the fact
that he's like the PR rep yeah no I saw
a headline today I guess it is like a
slow news day for celebrity gossip rags
because page six was like Chet Hanks you
know throw shade at people stocking up
on toilet paper and it's like so is
everyone you know its Rajee society is
looking down on people who start out on
toilet paper but like we're we waiting
to hear what Chet Hanks thought of these
people I am really like I for one was
I'm looking down on people who are like
a you know one person in a house with
50,000 rolls of toilet paper and I'm
really looking down on people but I'm
very close to running out of toilet
paper I have some because my husband
happens to be a hoarder which in this
situation proved to be fruitful because
he did his annual stocking up toilet
paper like right before this all
happened and then I asked him the next
day I was like by the way why did you
buy all that toilet paper and he was
like because we need a toilet paper I
was like are you aware that there's a
shortage right now and he was like no
and he was saying I was like oh well you
did something really good and he was
like oh cool I was watching Stryker's
Instagram stories and she was like
trying to be funny like throwing it
showing all the toilet paper her and
Taylor John he got in they literally
ordered it on Amazon like over a week
ago and it arrived and everyone's like
that is so out of touch
so she's literally shipping it to people
who need it like she got really called
out and she's doing the right thing and
you know what we had absolutely no
choice but to respect that I just don't
understand my toilet paper became the
thing that people like panic bought
because toilet paper is something that
if you didn't have it and you were in a
bind like you could make do paper towels
tissues you really desperate like a real
towel or you just hop of the shower
after every time you take a dump
ya know you
if we were really desperate in every
woman's out of toilet paper like you
could use a real towel and wash it like
back like you would have done back in
the day yeah also you can survive
without toilet paper like you can't
survive without food water yeah so I
just don't understand that why that
became the thing yeah I don't know I
don't know either but you just panic
like people someone decided to buy
toilet paper then the whole country did
yeah that's just so weird seeing some of
these videos of people like beating up
old people in supermarkets to get the
last roll of toilet paper seen like -
I've seen a few it's horrifying like we
should be ashamed I know I can't believe
there are people out there like that I
know it's really sad you know because
like from what I see an inserter I'm
like everyone's really here for each
other yeah but like the sociopaths don't
have Instagram that's how you know it's
like that's what's frustrating even like
when people are posting on Instagram
like how you can help the elderly like
if you know someone bah bah bah or like
putting up things yeah if you like reach
out to me if you need groceries and it's
like the elderly are non Instagram like
how are they going to see this I don't
know I just have to assume like
hopefully at least every elderly person
in the world like has one person who
like looks out for them I have to I just
that helps me sleep at night I can't
think of the other I just can't yeah I
can I like you know whether it's like a
grandkid or like a nurse IRA neighbor I
have to i literally refuse to believe
that there I know that there are but
like I refuse to believe that there is I
can't think of where old people are
being neglected it says that yeah it's
it's oh yeah Alba and tormund well how
old are both of them a Juris Elba is 47
okay no not right warmand Giantsbane
is unclear I feel like he's like a
hundred and seven yeah yeah he's been
around for since before the wall so I
think that actually makes him like a
thousand years old yeah he must need
some Giants milk I mean yeah from the
teat of a giant a Juris elbows like a
little old but he'll get through it like
I have absolutely no fears I I support
and I just hope he's okay and I really
want his daughter or whoever that was
just like it and get the [ __ ] out to
stay safe yes I saved yeah okay well I'm
also speaking of just like people
posting things on Instagram you and I
were talking about this yesterday about
how like certain people like in their
coronavirus content like on Instagram
strays are being so out of control like
out of touch and just like such a bad
example to be setting forward and Jackie
and I were like we really want to do a
segment
like all the people who we think are so
out of control but like we're never
gonna like name-drop people because
that's like so mean and like yeah they
follow us on Instagram we follow them
yeah but it work right yeah I would love
to hear from for maybe some of the
toasters like maybe want to tweet at us
who do you think is doing the worst job
of you know sending out positive
information you know try not to instill
fear and panic in people like who's the
most out of touch yeah I have a few
people in mind I had some pet peeves
from the weekend where it was people who
were out and and also saying they were
social distancing like if you're just
gonna be out just do your thing and do
it quietly but don't pretend like you're
following the rules that's very ok that
was my old pet peeve you are not my new
pet peeve is what people who are like
creating so much content like on their
Instagram story so tell me about this
doing tutorials oh no this is different
and then like people who are like what
do you want to see from me like during
this time and it's like nothing that
we're like whatever you go what are you
doing like we still don't care about
your skincare routine like still no
one's asking yeah that's my new pet
peeve people are using it as opportunity
to do the most when when it comes to
Instagram I do the most every day it's
just like now more people are watching
my Instagram views like story views have
gone up like double because I know just
sitting at home eating it's really
inspired me to like make it more premium
and usually I don't share I used to but
now I don't like share every thought in
my head when I'm watching what I think
about it but now I'm going back to doing
that because he was so funny about the
multi yesterday oh my god I was yeah
that guy he's you're guaranteed to get
your show canceled to get your show
cancelled guaranteed to be pre premium
mediocre content yeah this is my
favorite kind of Content ID then I
googled him he's been in everything that
I love Mad Men Desperate Housewives and
he's never like the star and does what
house was he was probably like just some
murderer you know yeah of course and
he's also a hallmark King oh wait
speaking of content Jackie and I filmed
some premium Tech Talks on our channels
yesterday if you wanna go check it out
grow with no job in Jackie oh and
speaking of content if you're thinking
about posting pictures of us you know
you're watching work from home toast
take a picture
we knew gifs for you to use they were
made by an amazing toaster who we found
on Instagram because she made these
really cute graphics of us her Instagram
is Alexandra v and she made these
fabulous chips so if you're on Instagram
and you want to use more toasty gifs
search at the morning toast like the
outside of the morning toast and all of
them will come up we have new ones of
Thea wood says P John everything of the
sort
really cute shout-out to Alexandra for
making them Thank You girlfriend and
check it out check
I feel like everyone even like not
content creators everyone is just really
focusing on their Instagram this week
because there's actually nothing else to
do yeah I can't tell you how many times
I've got that message like you are fully
caught up oh yeah no I never get that
message I never caught up and I think
that probably triple the amount of
people who like normally tag us like
watching the morning show it's live it's
now I get a million more tags and
Instagram stories oh of course it's just
just so engaged we're so glad to be in
your living rooms you guys okay ready
for our next story because it's actual
sub news because Reese Witherspoon is
must have something coming out because
she's just been all over town recently
and now she's on the cover of Vanity
Fair being such a cutie she's so cute
and talking about what inspired her to
start her production company which is
literally everything of the sort every
book I read someone's like this is being
a hell of sunshine this is turning into
a well we sway there see I don't know
who's in charge and I don't know if it's
Reese Erlich her people but whoever like
built the brand around Reese Witherspoon
did the most amazing job like she
started this reading list and then the
production company started turning the
reading list into movies like in TV
shows she's just a genius like she went
from just being like a Katherine Heigl
like a rom-com star to not only being
nominated for Oscars but being more of a
producer being a bigwig yeah she's an
inspiration I would say she said you
know I don't think she was ever gonna
come back from that remember when she
got arrested and the dashcam was like do
you know I am America's Sweetheart like
you that was the worst like the most
horrifying thing ever I mean I think she
could come back from it but she did
bigger and better than ever
yes she really that I had forgotten
about that I never forgot Reese
Witherspoon was so bothered by a
magazine article that called her
washed-up that she launched the hitch
HBO show big little lies and eventually
got women at the network equal pay
according to a new Vanity Fair profile
an actress came up to me at a party and
said do you know what you've done I had
no idea what she was talking about HBO
had called her agent to rewrite her
contract she was then paid twice as much
as she had been so she's getting women
paid bored she's getting more content
produced she's getting honestly better
content per degree and she's everything
of the sort and it's really amazing what
she's done I think the best part of that
it is that it feels like every step has
just been like the net just the logical
nacho not like she's had this big
corkboard plan with how am I gonna take
over but it's just like oh I didn't like
the way you talked about me here I'm
gonna go and make him like make movies
for myself that I can start and that
where I can thrive and now you know what
I like the process of making movies I'm
gonna do this for other people and help
out in the equation I also love like
people who openly admit that they're
like motivated or even just affected by
what liked a boy say saying about them
because you put celebrities on a
pedestal and you just think oh they're
not affected by what people say about
them like it's just a part of being a
celebrity they chose this life
but at the end of the day they're all
just people so knowing that Reese
Witherspoon has been it like upset by
what Star magazine said about her like
makes me relate to her on such a real
level yeah if I thought it was in New
Yorker magazine article so I just want
to throw that out
oh so it's even more like that's hurtful
I love the direct shade yes that's
actually really hurtful yeah
washed up never there was never a point
in her career when she was washed up no
I mean no no because she she was doing
like Legally Blonde but then she was
also winning Oscars for walk the lines
you know I don't know what at what point
she would have been considered washed-up
I do think around the time where she was
arrested she did go through like a low
point maybe it was around then I'm sure
but I don't think that translates to
washed-up no I mean you know that's a
thing to say but I mean if anyone ever
called me washed-up I would just be
grateful that at one point I was like
washed down no no I completely agree I
would see the positive in that but I
could see why like a megastar like she
really knew she was washed down wouldn't
mean you don't want to become washed up
yeah I just it told that and seeing you
know the positive you know he hang the
glass half-full and to me there's
there's there's something there's a
bright sky after every storm
yeah it's like I'd rather be a husband
than it never was that is so beautiful
like I I relate to that on such a deep
level like oh my god that's sick
stunning thank you thank you guys can
quote me okay you ready for our next
story I don't know I'm just feeling
really inspired like that that kind of
that really like my my body is like whoa
you know that it's because you just put
into words exactly like that was weird
exactly how you feel yeah yeah well I
just want you know I was like trying to
think of the words while you were
speaking it took me a second to toukas
usual I would ramble until I stumble it
out but I was able to package it nicely
for you guys you know what another thing
people should be doing is while they're
like you know spending downtime at home
you know getting their lives together
people who are single I feel like this
is a great time so I get on OKCupid and
start theirs
like the present if you haven't heard
about OkCupid yet we're here to tell you
why should why you should give it a shot
in 2020 a lot of people don't know that
OkCupid has really changed the game they
ask you the most thoughtful questions on
the app so that they can learn more
about who you are and what type of
person you're looking for the more
questions you answer the better they
aren't finding the matches you have some
something in common with so some of the
questions they ask they're very atypical
it's not stuff you would normally think
they ask if you're a dog or cat person
do you listen to podcasts about how long
do you want your next relationship to be
how do you feel about kids they're more
pertinent to the situation questions and
that's why we really like them here at
the morning shows and the best part
about OkCupid is that most importantly
it actually works it's the most
mentioned dating app in the New York
Times wedding section it is the only app
in the world that can match you on a
range of issues that you care about from
whether or not you're a dog or a cat
person to how you feel about climate
change step the mindless time on dating
apps and go to the app where you choose
what matters OkCupid is free human
connection is more important than ever
with OkCupid you can you can connect
with someone interesting online even
planned a virtual date download OkCupid
today to connect with someone great and
I've said this once I've said this
before if I have inspired you through my
beautiful ads to go on OkCupid and find
the love of your life I will not only
attend your wedding I will officiate and
perform a acoustic version of toast by
Claudia joy Wow I love that sign on fine
love I also need to clarify something
that I said maybe it's fake
no I didn't but I guess there's been
some speculation that the influencer I
was talking about about we still don't
care about your skincare routine is
snitch okay you know when you were
saying that I'm like you're actually
describing some of the tendencies Margot
hasn't been doing it but like I
absolutely care about her skincare
routine video I did ask for her makeup
tutorial and I know that literally
people ask her for her makeup tutorial
all the time but she does not have the
time and finally this snitch has the
time on her hands to give us that
content I'm talking about the people who
have been giving us that content all the
time yeah 24/7 like no ever like once a
year I make my everyday makeup tutorial
routine and I know that there are people
who are interested in that I'm talking
about when it's like literally once a
week you're dropping like tutorials
scale I carry different makeup routines
do you have still like nobody was asking
I was not talking about the signature
because I'll tell you who was asking the
[ __ ] campers were asking yeah I
watch that whole 14 minute tutorial it
was fabulous
I watched Margo's whole 14 minute
tutorial where every product she used
was empty and that's when you know like
that's a that's a real [ __ ] that's a
real [ __ ] using her everyday makeup I
had no clue she used one of those face
things gwasha do you use no Olivia's
been talking about a gouache off forever
it's like a piece of crystal that's um I
don't know if it's real crystal but it's
shaped in a way where it contours your
face and deep puffs Olivia you just
wasn't used with like a serum or an oil
Olivia's been talking about it forever
and like now everyone's using it and
Olivia's like upset because she do think
she deserves credit for inventing the
washa
but Margo uses it to some things like
that like in the Jade Roller look I'm
sure that they work in theory but they
do not work on my face no I got a Jade
Roller I put it on my forehead and I got
I'm gave myself a migraine and then I
was done I think I literally moved my
brain pieces around I'm sure people are
doing it wrong know what I didn't do
anything crazy with it like I just
rolled my forehead I don't know I think
there are certain people who washes and
Jade rollers work for like people with
not real faces but I have a real fleshy
face with like you know moles and bumps
and grooves and I just don't think I was
made for like the GWACs Jade Roller life
but I'm happy for other people I'm not
gonna get their gums but for me it's
just like what is this piece of plastic
I want to do to my face I know but I did
really enjoy watching her do it and then
it makes her face super red but then it
calms down but if my face got really red
it stays really red then I wouldn't be
able to like do makeup over it but I
loved seeing it from the cement and then
you would look embarrassed this is what
the kids are doing yeah so I definitely
asked for her makeup routine I asked for
that and it wasn't talking about her in
the slightest sure in the slightest
right what's that sorry okay Jennifer
Lawrence and cook Maroney restrain
alleged intruder at their LA home this
story is crazy because not only has an
intruder barged into Jennifer Lawrence's
home while she was home but like in
these Korona times no this is such a
weird story because you read it and it's
like oh my god someone went into her
house while her and her husband were
home but homegirl didn't even make it
past the front door because I guess she
had a security guard on her front door
and I know that celebrities have a lot
of security but I never really thought
they would have like a bodyguard
standing at their front door but I guess
they do yeah she walked through the
front door yeah but she was stopped
before she could enter the foyer
yeah I mean thank god that's so crazy
what if she had coronavirus this is my
worst nightmare
I mean this happens to Taylor Swift all
the time but not when Taylor Swift is in
the house it's like her homes in she's
when you have so many homes like some
guy is always running in and sleeping in
her bed and like that's scary but you're
not there so it's not that scary to you
personally but to me like someone being
in your physical
while you're home like there's nothing
scarier than that shook like you open
your medicine cabinet you closed it in
the person's right behind you
Cook was shucks cook was Chuck the girl
wasn't the girl was detained and a
source when I read this on page six said
that the girl wasn't looking for
Jennifer Lawrence but did she stumble
into the wrong house she was just
looking to like steal toilet paper and
food maybe it's already starting maybe
the crime has started you know maybe
that's scary
I don't know been watched the last night
when we finished hunters and we didn't
finish till like 1 o'clock and Ben
always does the nighttime walks and it's
not that scary at night I'm in New York
like a lot of stores are still open like
it's like a 24-hour City there's doorman
then calls me he was like literally you
cannot hang up it's pitch-black outside
everything is closed there's no doorman
outside he was freaking out it was like
I he literally said it would sound like
the purge like someone was about to come
out like break a store window Wow huh
that's crazy
we don't have a curfew yet in New York
but people say that that's what's coming
well it wouldn't affect me what about
dog walks I don't know I have to let
people walk their dogs I don't know you
could just like walk your dog to the
store like you know and then you're like
oh I'm not violating curfew curfews are
like crazy I know that's like real like
huh meanest [ __ ] you know yeah that's
when it gets real and it's like it's not
like you can get current events at a
later hour more than earlier in the day
yeah but I guess the curfew was meant to
decrease the pasta the potential of
crime yeah that's true and I'm not going
anywhere anyway so I wouldn't even know
the difference
oh it's also st. Patrick's Day happy st.
Patrick's Day it's gonna be so festive
yeah okay next up a little happy news
Malika Hawk gives birth to her first Oh
Malika Hawk is officially a new mom the
reality star announced that she gave
birth to a baby boy named ace on
Saturday March 14th oh my god that is so
cute and I love the cheetah boy because
I think that hurt him and true are gonna
be soul mates
wait this is just such an interesting
time like to be giving birth you know
hospitals are overcrowded um I just for
kids I'm not pregnant I don't like think
about that but there's so much going on
and it's just like people are also still
giving birth yeah I think I know people
are also getting sick and getting in car
accidents and that's why the hospitals
are really over mom because it's not
just coronavirus cases it's like
everything else that goes on in day to
day life wow that's crazy so she had a
boy that's so cute I'm so happy for her
she
was pregnant like four five minutes I
feel like we just reported her
announcement sponsored by clear blue
yeah but I think that's just because
she's been low-key which I love to see
because I hate when I'm like counting
down the days till someone else's
pregnancy yeah there were a couple
people who felt like they were pregnant
for 35 years Amy Schumer yeah well
getting of an inch it was pregnant like
a really you know but she didn't even
announce till five months right but
we're just so embed yeah maybe that's
why I love this name a safe for us face
is a cute name it's also the name it's a
place for the helper hardware store ooh
it's also what app kandi Burruss named
her baby so it's like a popular like a
new generational name yeah that's like
last month it was dove we had to baby oh
we love babies named of who was the
other one but sadly how crow oh yeah and
who was the attorney Mellencamp yes I
love that name it's like dove Cameron I
love the name dove - very spiritual very
spiritual well congrats to the Hawks -
Khloe and I don't know true is now older
I mean I'm so antiquated but like to me
it's like you know the man she's an
older woman yeah she's a cougar yeah
well I feel like she's like maybe that's
why she wears the headbands to age down
so she looks like a baby so she looks
like a baby because she is a baby she's
so cute so cute I think I don't be
really I'm excited for Khloe and Malika
to just be moms together I get like this
is so fun especially now that Khloe is
single like this probably not how she
pictured like her first few years of
motherhood and now she can do with
Malika that's so fun I know we have an
awesome family
you think she's back with Tristan I
think she is like Kim stories about
Tristan on his birthday were so nice
yeah I'm loving but he is the father of
their niece yeah but still yeah I know I
don't know if they're together
there's so many conflicting reports and
I genuinely like I care so much about
the Kardashians I care about every fart
they make every breath they take but I
don't give a [ __ ] about whether or not
Khloe interesting are together like they
beat that dead horse in the media and I
just don't care mm-hmm
so whatever well fifth and final story
actually the really big news of the day
is that Tom Brady has announced he's
leading the Patriots I mean is he said
quote it is time for me to open a new
stage Tom Brady was drafted by the New
England Patriots back in 2000 and has
spent his entire NFL
with the team now he is saying goodbye
Millennials but he's not saying goodbye
to football is saying about them right
he is a free agent now he's go to play
somewhere else even though he's never
played for another team in his life and
I just think that this is a [ __ ]
craziness like why are you leaving bro
your kids are in school no I think that
this is so weird and unnecessary like
it's one thing if you want to retire
like you have more money than God you
have a full life full family I totally
get that but to go to another team and I
don't know much about sports but to me
it's like to been drafted and then stay
at the same team for twenty years is
like a legacy that people only dream of
right now I'll probably like flounder on
a couple teams they won't win like it's
just no it's not about how good or bad
Tomas he they just won't win so now
he'll have like a joke of a career for
the last few years that's always what I
don't think it'll be a joke but it won't
be the prestige worldwide that he'd been
enjoying but I asked Zach about it this
morning I said where is he gonna go and
Zach had some interesting theories he
thought he might go to Florida to the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers because Florida is
a nice place to live and then he also
thought he might go to California to the
Chargers because Tom Brady's originally
from California and the Chargers our new
team and they're you know spot and they
have a new stadium opening so he could
like you know grow with the team and I
think it's know it sounded to me like
he's looking for nicer weather yeah I
mean I get why someone wouldn't want to
stay in Boston like it's cold and maybe
it's not for everyone but I just think
this is so strange and I think it's
really gonna shake up like football
fandom forever because people are such
big Boston fans but they might not be
Boston fans without Tom Brady and then
people are such Tom Brady fans but maybe
they won't be Tom Brady fans if he's not
in Boston yeah and it's like we actually
don't have any proof that Tom Brady can
play football not on the Patriots so
like what if he can't even like Castro
after this well he does not catch it I
just like his whole life that maybe he
doesn't like New England anymore but
like his whole life is there for 20
years like he has so many kids and
Giselle and like it seems like they have
a nice life even though I don't really
know much about it but I have breaking
news from the snitch from deadline it
says where is Tom Brady going next he is
launching a production company love that
for him with help from Avengers
directors Joe and Anthony Russo I
absolutely love this if he's gonna
become like a John Cena the rock you
know venture into acting but the
statement made it seem like he was
ending his he wasn't ending his football
career he was just ending the Patriots
yes it is no but
so actually this makes more sense as to
he could be going to the Chargers
because he is pursuing you know
Hollywood I don't think he's gonna be an
actor I think he wants to be a producer
Chargers I thought it was the Rams Zach
said the charger no the LA Rams I know
for sure the LA Rams but there's a
California Chargers team there's a
California Chargers team okay there's
gotta be can someone can someone say
what city they're from anyways here's
San Diego San Diego oh I can see that
for them do you know by the beach their
beaches in LA the big question in sports
right now remains whether six times
Super Bowl champion Tom Brady finishes
his career with the New England Patriots
or signs as a free agent elsewhere
deadline has learned that Hollywood will
be part of the long term plan for the
record-setting quarterback with the help
of the directors of the all-time biggest
grossing film Brady is launching 199
productions a global multi-platform
content company to develop original
premium content premium content
including documentaries changes
everything I didn't realize it was gonna
be premium no I had no idea I thought I
was just gonna be like content n
documentaries feature films and TV shows
the company has quietly assembled a
slate of development projects that
include several with Brady on camera in
story spanning sports entertainment and
health and wellness among them wow this
is very TNN of him Barry he's following
the steps of I believe Reese Witherspoon
was according checking when your
comments we just must address the
Chargers did move to LA so there are two
teams in LA right Wow Wow Wow
I mean the more the more that's
unfolding from the story here at and I
think we're really the only sports show
on the air today ESPN do closed their
doors did they I don't know I actually
know Zac has been watching like he
watches a lot of sports news and it's
like what are they talking about there's
no games they're playing old games and
then they just do this thing that he
likes to do where they predict what
people are gonna wear on the web carpet
and it's like the dumbest thing yeah
they just particularly who's gonna win
who's gonna go where how yeah he's gonna
handle it and like Ben was being so
weird last night like he just wouldn't
get into bed he's like I just need to
like do something he literally wrote a
cover song to look at this photograph
every time I do it makes me laugh he
wrote it about Bill DeBlasio he was
saying
it's actually really funny but he was so
bored he's like I never realized how
much my life truly revolves around
sports yeah
has he been watching those throwback
games that they're playing on TV
he's just been playing so many video
games like it's not working yes video
games yeah need to be stimulated like
all right so go out for a walk or
something yeah they can go play Monopoly
somewhere I just can't deal with like
the complaining you know what I mean
it's like we're in this together if I
have to like I'm okay like I know
obviously this is not ideal I would love
to be like out working going to meetings
but this is the the situation and like
you complaining is just making it worse
yeah yeah I agree and at least you guys
have th EO watch like I don't even have
that like that love in your life like
that yeah no I mean I literally tried to
convince you when we went to Dallas six
months ago to get a dog and if maybe you
had listened to me you may now be in the
warm loving arms of your son but no of
my little man no I know I've been using
this quarantine as an opportunity to
remind Zack that like this is why we
need a little John the chicken-hearted a
so [ __ ] cute okay should we dive into
our recap segment where we talk about
all the things we've been watching on TV
since we've been quarantined get into
first the toasts movie of the day um and
this whole segment is brought to you by
Missouri jewelry what if we told you
that you could wear fine jewelry every
day without it costing a fortune are
waiting for a hand-me-down from your
grandma with Missouri you get ethically
sourced fine jewelry without ever having
to choose between high-quality and fair
prices they drop new pieces every Monday
all versatile enough to be styled with
anything you own from day to night be on
the lookout each week for fresh and
exciting pieces sometimes under 150
dollars we're talking 14 karat gold
solid staples solid gold staples that
don't wear out or scratch easily they
have sterling silver pearls and even
diamonds Missouri is all about high
quality below maintenance because fine
jewelry is precious but you don't have
to be Precious about it Missouri's like
the company everyone like needs in their
life because I'm all about like dainty
jewelry but when you buy it online you
have absolutely no idea when it comes
from and like you wear it once that it
turns your finger green um so but once
you want to have a cute auntie look but
you also want it to be good and that's
where Missouri steps in so head to
Missouri dot-com / toast or use the code
toast at checkout for 10% off your first
order if you're looking to spice up your
life a little bit
that's Maj you are i.com slash toast for
10% off your first order missouri
dot-com slash toast or use the code
toast to check out for 10% off your
first order and thinking Missouri for
sponsoring
this following this upcoming segment
where we recap all the things that we
are watching while being quarantined
because there's literally nothing else
to do we assigned a movie last night as
a part of our toast movie of the day
program and it was the invention of
lions starring Ricky Gervais and
Jennifer Garner okay we watch this movie
a few years ago I mean and it came out
in 2009 so we watched it 11 years ago
yeah and III don't remember when I was
watching it I thought I thought that I
had remembered loving it but then the
more I was watching it I think I
remember the feeling it kind of came
back to me the feeling was that this is
a really interesting concept for a movie
a movie like this utopia of lying not
ever being invented um but it did get a
little like drawn-out at the end yeah it
was really star-studded like Philip
Seymour Hoffman
Rob Lowe Tina Fey Ricky Gervais Jennifer
Garner louis c.k who i saw that guy and
i was like i was like that guy looks
familiar i wonder what he's been in i'm
a redheaded friend yeah and then I
looked at our Instagram post and it had
the names at the top I was like oh Louie
CK also the girl who was the
receptionist at the nursing home she's
June from don't trust me she's also the
loser from Gossip Girl like the wannabe
yes she's in Basel I want to say loser
yeah but she's actually beautiful she
looked really beautiful in the movie it
was this is the thing conceptually it
was interesting and I like to see how
they created this society where there
was no lying like when they were showing
TV commercials or advertisements or her
movies like you couldn't make up
something fictional so you would just
retell history and a movie it was all
very interesting but it was so boring
like I literally couldn't get off my
phone and it was like where is this
gonna go you know like how are we gonna
end this thing and even and where she he
admits to her what he's been doing but
not to the rest of the world like it
just like didn't feel like justice was
served
it was so disingenuous and then they
ended up getting married and and she
never knew that part of the reason why
she like loved him and was impressed by
him was not real yeah like I feel like
she was duped oh and also the DEA from
law and order was in it Alex Cabot yes
she was the girl that had to have sex
with him on the street or the world was
gonna end it was honestly too such a
dumb movie and Ricky Gervais swimming me
really depressed in the beginning like
his life was so sad in the hell oh yes
he sat apartment building where Jonah
Hill was like every night trying to kill
himself like it was just so depressing
and I don't know what the
message was like if you want to have a
good life you have to lie but then it's
like even if you lie you won't be happy
yeah I think ultimately the message was
there's a lot of different themes but I
think the message and it is best
displayed in Jennifer Garner who still
is not someone who lies but realizes
that there is more to life than like
looks and DNA compatibility yeah and
like if he hadn't lied to her she would
have never given him that chance so I
think it's that sort of message that you
know beauty is beneath the surface
because you would never get to that
point with someone if you we just judge
people based on their looks yeah
but then also there's this weird theme
that religion is a lie oh yeah I mean
that was like subliminal messaging yeah
about like the man in the sky and the
tablets but it was all a lie yeah and
it's like within it sit in a society
without lies we don't have religion
because religion is alive that's
actually very true yeah it was just
honestly it would have been more
interesting as like a short film like we
would never watch a short no but to me
like the part of the reason why it was
so bad it was because it was two hours
of silliness when the silliness in the
beginning was kind of like funny and
interesting to watch but then it just
got so stupid we're like everyone was
just like yeah it also showed me how
like cults can easily form because when
people are looking for some sort of
guidance standing and guidance and
someone could literally make anything up
and you're just gonna believe it because
that's what you want to believe
um cult cult 'back coltie vibe it wasn't
my favorite movie but one I thought
would provoke interesting conversation
and maybe for the most part that it did
yeah but let's assign our movie for
tomorrow because this one is sure to be
a showstopper yeah because it's one of
our favorite movies like a lot of time
and I think a lot of you might have seen
it but I think a lot of people actually
haven't seen it I also haven't seen it
in a while yeah and I could watch it
it's likely leave on like I could watch
it every day for the rest of my life and
be satiated it has a star-studded cast
Jennifer Love Hewitt Sigourney Weaver's
arguably her finest work um who's that
that guy hurt jennifer Love Hewitt's guy
love interest yeah hold on let me do it
who does she fall in love with uh you
know that nice guy and he has the bar Oh
Sarah Silverman's in it oh the nice guy
with the bar yeah
the movies called heartbreaker or
frakerz Heartbreakers it's on Netflix
it's stars Jennifer Love Hewitt and
Sigourney Weaver it's you know a ragtag
team of con woman women yes um Jason Lee
is his name who plays um the guy but
that didn't like give me the sort of
satisfaction that I needed you know yeah
what he's from I'm familiar hold on what
else is he from I'm sure Ray Liotta is
in it
he plays Sigourney Weaver's love
interest it's a great movie also that
star studded even if you've already seen
it you know that it's good and like
that's you'll want to re-watch it and if
you haven't seen it you are seriously
missing out like that old guy I feel
like vomiting
I don't really always say that to
Claudia when I feel like vomit and it's
like it's from that obscure line from
the movie I feel like vomiting it's a
great movie it is uh necks by the way we
have like so many Canadian toasters and
I guess Canada to Canada Netflix is
different than Canadian I mean American
Netflix but we can only pick movies that
we see on American Netflix so I
apologize to the Canadian toasters
because the invention of lying was not
on Netflix Canada but hopefully
Heartbreakers is yeah or it has to movie
hopefully it's on another platform it's
such a good movie I'm actually really
excited to watch it tonight like
yesterday went by really quickly
actually access of all the homework
assignments and content like we did the
toes so that could see about till noon
that mean watch a mention of lying then
I was stuck and I didn't know which way
to go and I went in the direction of the
bowl type and I would just I like to
talk about it I've heard about it too
it's it's kind of a combination of
younger Sex in the City
Carrie Diaries where it's like no you
know what it Ryan to me most have a
younger right but then when it came out
I did a sponsorship with free form and I
watched the first two episodes because I
got paid to do it and I thought it was
cute it's super cute a lot of people
have been telling me to watch it over
the years they tell you that it's very
steamy and it's weird because so due to
streaming i streamed it on hulu okay and
I think all seasons are there so if you
guys want to watch with me I think I'm
coming up on like Episode five now um
and I'll recap it as I finish I continue
to watch or even after an hour I think
they feel like an hour okay but I don't
know no they're done thirty minutes is
so short those episodes apply yeah I
think it's like 40 minutes um
so overall I'm enjoying it and I think
it's perfect I'm spending a lot of time
in my phone though barely paying
attention and it's
because sometimes I really like shitty
content like I could watch so many
hallmark movies but then like I can deal
with a cheesy content yeah and it's they
work at a magazine it's supposed to be
too cosmopolitan okay and I like the
girls they're cute friendship but there
were just so many things that bother me
and I really think that Jane and Kat
need to be fired because they're
absolutely terrible employees and they
continue to bring their personal lives
into the workplace and they continue to
[ __ ] up on the job and the only person
who I absolutely stand is Sutton and
like she's also having an affair well
neither of them are married but she's
hooking up with the guy the guy the guy
who's gonna get your show cancelled and
it's good but the the editor-in-chief is
like suppose to be like Anna Wintour
like Joanna
what's that monocles bye yeah and it's
like she's nothing in the story so like
just wants the best friends with the
three girls like she's so up their ass
and in their lives it's crazy and it's
like she's she's just a weird
editor-in-chief do you recommend that we
started yeah I don't know you should
start it and then we could talk about it
on the show
okay well now my docket is free because
I finished Hunters now if you're in the
middle of a tour you plan on watching it
just meet me really quickly because I'm
going to spoil the ending because it was
so incredibly [ __ ] stupid like the
whole show I thought was so well done
like I literally cried so much like they
really did such a good job of showing
how like survivors living in America
like their life was never the same like
it was just totally ruined and all the
things that they went through in the
camps it was really done really really
well
and then this overall storyline that
like America secretly brought Nazis into
the u.s. because they were really good
scientist and they didn't want the
Russians to take them so like they put
them working at NASA they put them in
politics and like that whole it was just
really interesting they were hunting
them it was all exciting and like the
FBI was like getting in the way of the
hunters and so Al Pacino plays Mayer
Offerman who was in Auschwitz or one of
the camps I'm I might not have been
Auschwitz and he is his life's mission
he was very successful after the war he
lives in this big fancy mansion in New
York and he put together this team of
people at hunt Nazis because he found
out that America was bringing them in to
work in various fields and he's in
charge and he's like the moral compass
of the show he never lost his Jewish
faith or Jewish values and it's so
important like an eye for an eye doesn't
leave the world blinds because the best
kind of revenge is revenge I keep saying
everything like yeah you see a Nazi if I
can kill him
and the whole time all these Nazis are
killing them but there there's one
can't find the wolf and he was like a
Mangala type like they say he was worse
than Mangala and he tortured meyer
Offerman in one of the camps like made
him kill 11 Jews in the middle of the
night in the wood in the woods like this
guy was the worst and at the very end it
turns out that Meyer Offerman is the
wolf it was so not believable like this
Jim was actually a Nazi who felt so bad
that he took my offer he killed my
Offerman took his um name and likeness
and moved and wanted to he felt so bad
that he killed all these Nazis and he
wanted to learn he converted to Judaism
and became a real deal it was so not
believable it ruined the entire show
well and they figured it out and they
killed him and I'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding me but then there was still 20
minutes left and they had killed most of
the Nazis and like it was almost over
but and you thought that this woman the
colonel who was like trying to bring the
fourth reich she was in charge of
bringing Nazis to America she died they
her car went over or something but of
course you know they go to Argentina and
where she's there and it turns out this
shows about to end it's actually really
crazy and she's getting her family ready
for dinner they're living in this
mansion in Argentina the kids sit down
and she says she calls her husband come
on it's time for dinner ate off and it's
Hitler and he says thanks Eva and she's
Eva Braun and it's like it's this
potential world where ate off didn't die
and he's coming back so that was like
the end and that was the only thing that
kept me like I think I got a second
season but they lost me with how dumb it
was that that guy then the Jew ended up
being the Nazi like what kind of [ __ ]
message are you sending now I know why
people are obsessed with the show up set
up set up set up set so I'm glad I'm not
watching that I'm glad I'm watching
premium content like the bull tight and
I got so worried in these whole story
lines like it was so upsetting like
that's so upsetting oh my god and you
love Maya Offerman like he is like this
righteous Jew who's doing the right
thing and he knows everything and he's
everyone loves him and he's a [ __ ]
Nazi I'm are you [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] [ __ ] but then that little
twist with ate off at the end really got
to me damn what did the tha o think we
were up all night and of course second
night in a row I have dreams about
hunting Nazis like it's I I'm glad the
show's over because I couldn't
I was so afraid him when we were done
Ben went to go walk the old left me in
the apartment alone like I couldn't move
I was paralyzed with fear so I need to
watch something light maybe I will watch
the bolt I think that you should in
addition to heartbreak this is like
pretty cute and the girls are cute and
it's very you know young New Yorker I
love easy freeform show like young and
hungry is so good yeah no it's good and
preformed they do have like the
flexibility to you know show a nipple
raunchy no they don't show it they show
a man's nipple but it's funny cuz like
they're trying to free the nipple but
it's like even on your own show you
won't yeah that's funny anything else
that we need to discuss recap before we
wrap up I think that's it for me if
you're looking for more content we
released a patron episode last week Q&A
with me and Jackie so you can sign up
for patreon $8 a month you get five
extra episodes well Jenny or this week
if you sign up now you get access to all
the episodes that we've done so that
will get you through this corner it's
patreon.com slash the morning shows and
TNN shows are gonna be releasing
episodes the snatcher will be releasing
today Morrow Morrow maternity live will
be releasing Thursday so as long as
you're keeping up with tusk news network
following us on Instagram you'll be
aware of all the happenings here at
toast news network because we're
releasing content because we know that's
what you need yeah
that contents is gonna get us through
you guys so make sure to watch
Heartbreakers available on Netflix the
trust movie of the day we will recap it
tomorrow and we'll also do dear toasters
tomorrow which is our advice segment so
email us dear toasters at gmail.com we'd
like to keep it quarantine themed so if
you're having a quarantine problem that
you need advice on please email us but
if you're having a regular problem you
can email us too we always keep it
anonymous
dear toasters at gmail.com thank you yes
I just want to say once again reiterate
that we are so thankful for all of our
health care workers doctors nurses
everyone who is helping to contain this
virus and I just want to let you know I
saw this going around yesterday anything
it's really important to share that if
you are Co quarantined with an abuser
please reach out to the national
domestic violence hotline one eight
hundred seven nine nine seven two three
three because I didn't think of that
yeah it's really scary so um you can
also chat at the hotline org thank you
so much for listening to the morning to
us the Millennial morning show where we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you follow
us and you're watching on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
and leave a comment
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio IR
radio Kasbah
all the places whoever you listen to
podcast find us the money toast you
maybe subscribe leave a five-star review
I've had a beautiful study and smart we
are we love you guys so much we'll see
you tomorrow tomorrow